far from over and we've got Maurice with
a guest in Abidjan not just like yes any
old guests we have SOS C's who is the
president of the Orion Chess Federation
and also the man who put this all
together this wonderful event s so your
wildest dreams could you have imagined
you'd have the grand chest tour a couple
of years ago you might have you might
have had a fantasy about it and you're
the grand chest were the best chess
players in the world right here in Ibiza
well Maurice what can I say it's it's a
real we keep pinching ourselves you know
just players all over the country just
lovers in Cote d'Ivoire and in the West
Africa because we have the Nigerians the
ghanaians they are pinching themselves
there they they wonder whether they're
dead in paradise or really on earth
because this this there there was no way
to think about it to conceive of it let
alone to see it and to live it so it's
just wonderful you know three years ago
we met in South Africa and I remember
you getting on your knees and saying
please coach my team and the Olympian
flees buries a hobby shot needs things
like this an opportunity I couldn't
imagine three years later you've got
Magnus Carlsen in the building you and
also it's not just the beautiful thing
about that as well as let's also say the
things that you're doing with the young
people here in our vision they're gonna
be so inspired by it
tell us about your vision for combining
not just elite chess the chest and the
scholastic and yet youth level as well
my vision actually was shipped by
listening to those kids and when you
hear me say I want to be the greatest
chair chess player in the world you have
two choices either you try to spell that
you try to bring the opportunity to her
and motivated to do more or you just say
okay you know stop dreaming younger I
chose to try and bring chest to her and
to the other kids of Cote d'Ivoire they
are so thrilled Africa is grateful just
that's
I guess that's the line Africa the whole
of Africa is grateful for the
Grantchester coming to our continent
great symbolism to be sure but also
giving a different view a lot of people
have the wrong view of Africa they don't
realize how beautiful it is to be here
and then you bring all the West African
states a chess tournament you've got the
Nigerians as you mentioned you've got
players from Ghana
do you have Togo here as well logos use
Coco's here as well and of course your
players playing in Abidjan your vision
for the future I mean have you looked
that far
I had given that you still in the middle
of you know this wonderful success yes I
am my vision is this very simply put
just so Africa is not just a game for me
chess is an opportunity to lay down the
foundation for economic social personal
cultural development because chess is a
game that makes people naturally want to
and actually practice the art of making
good decisions good rational decisions
are the foundation for success any
success and of course there are a lot of
you know you know bad ideas circulating
chess is a game for the elite for the
wealthy for the most educated and you
know chess is not and playing playing in
Africa is not considered a good thing
kids should not be playing they should
be working especially young girls should
be helping their mothers in the kitchen
chess is changing all of this when when
father and mother and play chess with
their children in the home like we are
seeing now being done we are also
challenging the social you know
categories which social Iraqi and
leading people to think that the best
wins pawns can be promoted to Quinn's
and it's just a revolutionary kind of
opportunity that we want to bring to
African
and African families and community and
like I said sometimes we want a national
national development we want countries
that are developed but no country
develops itself without with individuals
citizens that are underdeveloped or or
not developed so for me chess is just
that and the response that we get
especially what we did with those young
kids using miniatures teaching chess in
elementary school for children aged five
to nine with the support of the Cote
d'Ivoire Ministry of Education we we
trained twenty two hundred and fifty
kids in 70 in 2017 2018
this year we absolutely and and we aim
to do this for seven thousand and five
hundred kids this year and thanks I need
to thank the Kasparov foundation from
Kofun for funding our first year pilot
project with mini chests but mind you
the minister of sports said in an
interview you know I'm the occasion of
the opening ceremony said welcoming the
crunches tour in Abidjan is an
opportunity for introspection for its it
makes us realize that just as a lot to
offer to côte d'ivoire and we have not
supported this chess federation the way
deserved to be supported and we are
going to support it properly from this
point on so what you know what can we
hope to achieve when the grand chest
tour visits a country better than the
ownership by the government and the
commitment by the government to support
chest and chest development in Africa I
see your passion I feel your passion we
could go on all day talking about this
but the work you're doing is simply
fabulous thank you so much for what you
offer for young people here in the hope
and showing the world just how beautiful
a place you have really congratulations
and wonderful thank you wonderful work
soé sees the president of the Aurora
Chess Federation you could feel the
man's passion just coming through the
screen and he has absolutely done
fabulous work here in Abidjan